breaking news from the so-called gig
economy and the supreme court
has ruled that drivers do work for uber
the tech giant's appeal has been
dismissed by the highest court in the
land
and it means that drivers should be
classed as workers
and not third-party independent
contractors well it means that they
should
then get basic employment rights like
paid holidays
the judgment is likely to have big
implications for tens of thousands of
drivers and indeed
people working in other gig sectors as
well well let's bring in
skies technology correspondent roland
manthorp
morning roland just remind us how this
ended up in the supreme court
morning well it ended up through this
absolutely epic struggle
which all began way back in 2016
when two drivers james farah and yasim
aslam
brought a case to the to an employment
tribunal
claiming that they were workers now they
were both uber drivers and it's
important to note there's a subtle
distinction here that's really important
british law has three categories of
employment
full employment self-employment
and worker status which is somewhere in
the middle
uber said the drivers were fully
self-employed
the driver said they had some rights but
could retain
some flexibility those drivers they won
in the employment tribunal
they won on appeal they won an appeal
again and again and finally
it got all the way to the supreme court
and what we've just had
is an absolutely sweeping milestone
judgment that i think will have
deep significance throughout the gig
economy
because the the supreme court justices
didn't
just unanimously rule against uber and
in favor of the drivers
finding that they are indeed workers
they also push this judgment
forward right across uber's business
model
there was always a question in this
judgment
whether the judges would look very
narrowly or what was going on
back in 2016 all that long time ago
when the case was originally brought and
uber has been saying for some time well
yes
okay maybe we did we weren't perfect in
2016 but we've
changed a lot since then we do things so
differently now
we're really unrecognizable from the
company that we were then reading
we only we don't have the full details
yet but from the judgment
that was just read out the judges seem
to say that the very
way that uber operates the heart of its
business model
means that its drivers are workers
this is a worst case scenario for uber
this will have
deep ramifications not just for them but
right across the gig economy
you